[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport le
magazine est considéré comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département c'est parti à pour le
sommaire box marvin petit mot qui
officiellement le titre wb à continental
après sa victoire contre samir kasmi par
k o
la décision était en suspens après les
débordements qui avaient entaché le
grand gala du samedi 20 janvier
nous recevrons son coach d'andy
farruggia sursaut pato dans quelques
instants
ils se portent une grande compétition
deux heures stone était organisée ce
samedi à l'hôtel de ville de versailles
centaine de participants s'est affrontés
sur ce jeu de cartes médiéval
fantastique les détails dans ce magazine
handball un grand match féminin sera
programmée ce week-end au vélotour
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
jeudi si paris joueront leur match de
coupe d'europe contre les liquides
d'origine des bipeurs christensen zoom
dans ce magazine projecteurs à présent
sur les principaux résultats à daisy
minois
[Musique]
on commence donc par de la boxe c'est
officiel marvin petit est le nouveau
détenteur de la ceinture wbc
continentale et intègre le top 10
mondial après plusieurs jours de débats
souvenez vous le samedi 20 janvier après
la victoire de l'élan courtois par ko
contre samir kasmi plusieurs dizaines de
supporters avaient envahi le ring pour
s'affronter
l'arbitré n'avait pas pu donner sa
décision pour nous parler de cet épisode
nous recevons sur ce plateau son coach
jean guy farrugia
bonsoir alors comment se sont passées
les jours qui ont suivi près de ce 20
janvier
on ne va pas dormir a téléphoné à gauche
à droite pour savoir savoir qu'est ce
qu'il en était présent également
voilà son côté la presse qui nous
appeler les gens qui nous a appelé pour
savoir où section était j'avais des 100
200 coups de téléphone par jour
ça donnait en données ou des fous et
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pendant ces
jours qui ont suivi vous avez eu des
instances rares gens savaient disons
qu'avec le temps on a des relations qui
ont commencé à connaître des gens donc
les gens nous appelaient donc je pouvais
pas ne pas décrocher nous appeler pour
me dire voilà moi j'ai fait ça moi j'ai
fait ça pour toi voilà ça va intervenir
maintenant c'est à l'autre de prendre la
décision parce que j'en étais y avait là
des la fédération mondiale a donné la
décision la fédération européenne et la
fédération française
donc c'était très beau et comment marvin
a vécu cette situation
il risque même d'être banni de la boxe
alors il était question que certains il
que la fédération française pas la
fédération mondiale où quelque chose
européenne mais la fédération française
voulait le sus pour moi et quand il
habitué lui serrer comme une injustice
parce que vu ce qui s'est passé
franchement là je parle pour marvin et
pour son peuple la communauté qui le lui
la femme est que médée des gitanes des
gitans à pas ils n'ont pas bougé un
petit doigt ils sont fait insulter sans
arrêt sans bouger un petit doigt jusqu'à
temps qu'ils reçoivent des chaises dans
la tronche
malthus laisse pas faire non plus et
qu'est-ce qui a fait pencher la balance
du côté de marvin petit pour qu'il
récupère cette ceinture bas il ya
beaucoup de gens que des arbitres qui
étaient là qui ont dit qu'ils ont vu
marvin essaie de calmer son public avant
de avant de péter les ponts ya des
témoignages qui ont aidé à marvin c'est
ça beaucoup de gens qui ont vu le père à
marvin de calmer des les calmer les gens
et conversion un coup de chaise
j'adore sa parole et la victoire encore
plus de saveur peut-être plus cette
victoire il la fallait il fallait
évidemment une victoire sur le ring
victoire également dans l'adhésion
concernant les travaux sur les instances
du ring mais
voilà c'est mais c'est bon après justice
a été faite bien sûr tout le monde
ces images à la salisse vraiment le
monde à la boxe le monde de la boxe oui
et le monde du sport oui parce que ça ça
arrive ça arrive au football aussi ça
arrive quand il ya eu les attentats on
n'a pas
enfin au match de foot on a dit que
c'était le foot la ce a rien à voir avec
le sport c'est vraiment ça ça lui le
sport en général les mecs de quartier en
plus parce que c'est vraiment des
ouvrages je sais pas ce qu'ils sont
venus faire quoi je prends ça salit
également peut-être l'image de marvin
petit nom à l'image de marvin petit au
contraire les mêmes les médias que ce
soit le journal de l'équipe tf1 canal+
beaucoup de beaucoup de gens sont
intéressés à marvin parce que justement
ils ont vu que en premier lieu calmer
les supporters avant de péter you a pété
les plombs après voilà donc sur le ring
par contre la victoire ne faisait place
à aucun doute un marvin a réussi à
remporter la 23e victoire de sa carrière
professionnelle en sept rondes par k o
il vous a surpris sur le ring surpris
non parce que je sais que marvin il a
des grandes capacités on en a déjà parlé
que si marine avait des envies il
pourrait devenir champion du monde est
il en train de devenir un la petit à
petit il a laissé un petit mondial il va
le devenir un grand mondial
et voilà il va devenir je pense champion
d'europe d'ici quelques mois il a
travaillé dur pour atteindre ce niveau
alors avant marvin il fallait le
chercher il fallait que j'aille le
chercher pour qu'il allait s'entraîner
bon avant homoboulot donc j'avais
cherché à 6 heures du matin pour aller
courir ou voilà un an et il va tout seul
et s'est même moqué le ralenti donc
c'est plus de même marvin vous pensez
que cet épisode peut encore le faire
progresser le faire mûrir encore un peu
plus il est assez gênant il a 27 ans 26
ans artisan il va voir 27 donc oui mais
non épreuve il mûrit en mairie tous les
jours et devient de plus en plus mature
en plus il va être papa donc ça change
beaucoup de choses qu'il fallait être
costaud pour gérer cette situation
ce 20 janvier alors il fallait être
costaud parce qu'on monte sur le ring
on se recevait des crachats avant de
monter sur le ring on recevait en se
faisait insulter
il a réussi à être concentré tout du
moins au combat sans répondre sans
quelque chose il regardait public
après il fallait être concentré par un
pâle pour penser qu'au combat ray dedans
oui il fallait être costaud vis-à-vis de
ça et quelle est la prochaine étape pour
marvin il a intégré le top 10 mondial
c'est un des champions du monde
maintenant non aujourd'hui on parle de
défense de titre
l'union européenne en italie je crois
aussi 16 mars au 17 mars
je ne sais plus trop voilà la façon il
est prêt marvin on va déjà il ya plus
quelque chose à faire maintenant on va
voir comment sa blessure est guérie
aussi et a été blessée à la tête en
menant ces incidents et la prime
copieuse
il s'est passé à quelques centimètres de
l'oeil voilà donc voilà sa femme ait été
choqué moins moralement celle à
l'hôpital depuis pas plus de kouméa
moralement elle a plaidé en fin bref
pour dire qu'on n'est pas des gens
violents et petit à petit voilà barbie
mais progresse et lala après je pense
que mois de mai mais jouent-ils frêche
en plein d'autres championnats d'europe
avant un championnat du monde a dit
c'est afin d'aller le championnat du
monde je suis pas pressé je suis pas
pressé parce que il a encore beaucoup il
a il ya encore quelques défauts à
corriger mais déjà là et le top 10 d ici
qui va être champion d'europe il sera
dans l'es5 donc quelques défenses de
titre et on est challenger
donc je
voilà faut aller doucement quand même
parce qu'il est jeune et man six ans et
je pense qu'il va être champion d'europe
champion du monde merci à vous tanguy
farruggia ou souhaitent de décrocher un
titre de champion du monde avec tanguy
farrugia votre votre mari petit bar dont
guy farrugia par une petit dans les
prochains mois merci beaucoup en tout
cas d'être venu sur ce plateau hameau de
rugby à présent jouer ce week-end la 14e
journée de fédérale 2 plaisir s'est
incliné 35 à 8 ce dimanche contre
beauvais à l'extérieur sur un terrain
boueux
au classement les plaisirs war est 10e
au port de la zone de relégation avec
six points d'avancé sur arras et neuf
sur de mon prochain match pour plaisir
le dimanche au 11 février à domicile
contre leurs oeufs les quatrièmes du
championnat
on continue à part du rugby mais cette
fois ci en division honneur belle
performance du sky rugby ce week-end les
joueurs saint quentinois se sont imposés
30 à 24 sur le terrain du cinquième la
nuit une victoire qui permet au club de
remonter à la sixième place du
championnat et de compter quatre points
d'avancé sur le premier relégable le rc
paris 15 le bilan du sky désormais de 4
victoires 1 nul et 7 défaites
dans l'autre poule de division honneur 2
sur 2 pour les équipes yvelinoise engagé
ce dimanche ce verset s'est imposé
contre vitry 27 à 5 à domicile au stade
de porchefontaine dans son côté
cheuvreux a réalisé une belle opération
en s'imposant 24 à 10 sur son terrain
contre goussainville
au classement les versailles et pointe à
la troisième place c'est chevreuse
remonte à la cinquième position et
s'éloigne de la zone de relégation
prochain match pour les deux équipes
dimanche 11 février c'était une grande
première dans une mairie en france plus
habitué à accueillir les cérémonies
officielles ou les soirées électorales
l'hôtel de ville de versailles a
accueilli ce samedi 1 3 de heath portes
du sport sur jeux vidéo
des centaines de joueurs se sont
affrontés sur le jeu médiéval
fantastique of stone un montage signé
son ring fauteuil 32 ordinateurs des
écrans géants l'hôtel de ville de
versailles s'est transformé en une salle
d'arcade j en ce samedi 27 janvier
au programme une compétition du célèbre
jeu médiéval fantastique
aston et discipline pratiquée par plus
de 70 millions de joueurs à travers le
monde
on a un père aux différents
c'est de faire des cars pack est de 34
ont réuni nos trois meilleurs cas on
choisit le héros qu'on veut et on
confondre notre héros au héros adverses
et on va avoir un système de points de
vie des produits c'est notre vie et le
but ça va être de mettre les point de
vue adverse à 0 pour ce premier rendez
vous du sport tas versailles 2
compétition était organisée en parallèle
la première réunit ces huit des
meilleurs joueurs de france
tous professionnels pré sélectionnés
parmi plus de 1000 candidats
la seconde et est ouverte à des joueurs
amateurs nous on considère que dans les
jeux vidéo
les gens ont l'habitude d'être actif
devant leur écran et donc on considère
que quand ils viennent c'est juste pour
regarder les joueurs et ben voilà ils
vont regarder une heure elles vont
regarder deux heures et puis bon
évidemment il va repartir
et donc ce mix des deux fait que les
joueurs jouent leur parti regardez
partie de projets leur parti et c'est
souvent quelque chose qui marche très
très bien
amateurs ou professionnels tous ont joué
cette compétition intensément comme de
véritables sportifs
certains joueurs se sont entraînés
pendant plusieurs semaines pour réaliser
des performances sur ce rendez vous il y
a une intensité qui le mental surtout
mais qui serait bientôt sur le physique
et derrière il faut aussi savoir
entretenir son corps enrichi c'est pas
le tout de jouer tout le temps sur le
deuxième sam harris faire du sport à
côté justement pour entretenir sa forme
mentale et physique des sacrifices
récompensés comme dans toutes les
compétitions sportives le vainqueur chez
les professionnels à remporter 1000
euros et des lots ont été distribués
chez les amateurs une nouvelle édition
pourrait être programmé à versailles
prochainement
on ouvre une page handball chez les
féminines après deux matches sans
défaite montigny le bretonneux s'est
incliné sur son terrain 23 à 22 face à
beauvais lors de la 11e journée de
nationale 2 une défaite lourde de
conséquences puisqu'elle renvoie lésigny
monteyne à la dernière place du
championnat à un point du premier non
relégable
montigny le bretonneux compte une seule
victoire depuis le début de la saison on
continue à parler de handball féminin
après avoir accueilli un match de
championnat en 2000 à 17 entre issy
paris brest le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines va accueillir
ce samedi 3 février une rencontre de
coupe d'europe
ici paris va défier l'équipe norvégienne
de vipère christiansen au 4ème tour de
la compétition pour nous parler de ce
grand rendez-vous patrick fiable
coordinateur local de l'événement est
avec nous en plateau pour soir bonsoir
alors je le disais précédemment après un
match de championnat cette fois ci c'est
un quatrième tour de coupe d'europe
oui qui va se dérouler au vélo
le rhum c'est une nouveauté par rapport
à l'année passée donc c'est pas sans
problème puisque quand on fait à la fois
championnat de france et coupe d'europe
les joueuses sont de moins en moins
disponibles faire la promotion c'est
difficile
donc bon pour l'instant on a déjà revoir
c'est un tour au match ah ça c'est ça
s'est jamais fait dans un vélodrome donc
c'est très bien et puis je pense qu'il
ya du spectacle puisque les les lionnes
d'ici paris ont gagné d'un but en
norvège
donc ça va être chaud samedi donc on
vous montre vraiment d'un cran le disais
c'est un match championnat maintenant un
match de coupe d'europe
fini l'une des meilleures équipes
norvégiennes aussi en face à ben ya du
beau monde dans l'équipe
donc il y avait des choses qui étaient
essentiellement des norvégiennes mais
présente aux championnats du monde du
mois de décembre
donc ça va être ça veut dire justement
la france avait remporté la finale des
championnats du monde en décembre contre
contre la norvège justement pensé que ça
sera une revanche il y aura un esprit de
revanche en tout cas chez ces
norvégienne il y aura je pense que ça va
mal de qualité puisque les norvégiennes
sont quand même un peu
les maîtresses du handball féminin donc
je pense que ça va être très plaisant et
puis pour gagner en norvège
il a fallu faire a vraiment un très très
bon match et les joueuses se sont
parfaitement préparés pour ce rendez
vous je pense que l'entraîneur arnaud
gandais dû faire le nécessaire pour
motiver ses troupes alors l'événement
avait attiré plus de 5000 spectateurs au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
en 2017
vous pensez qu'il y aura encore plus de
monde en tribune face à une première
c'est toujours on s'attend à une
deuxième édition un petit peu un
problème de tassement donc c'est vrai qu
est le fait d'un match de coupe d'europe
c'est plus mobilisateur pour l'instant
n'est pas loin de quatre lignes qu'admin
place devant du donc cette bonne augure
et puis on va bien voir vous allez
continuer à à toute façon il a donné des
prospectus à ouidah wildfire des flyers
justement ne se passe que les
inondations parfois leur importance au
niveau du déplacement au niveau des
déplacements puisque les les spectateurs
potentiels ont du mal à arriver sur les
lycées quoi que vous attendez les
supporters norvégiens pour cet ouvrage
je ne sais pas du tout
on verra je sais pas et tout est prêt à
cinq jours de l'événement
on est bon il reste à faire le pauvre
fils peaufinage des détails il est un
genre
la signalétique des choses comme ça quoi
accueillir
oui surtout que là ce sera sur un match
seul il n'ya pas d'animation avant donc
tous les gens vont arriver au dernier
moment
donc il va falloir absorber le flux des
personnes
donc c'est effectivement il ya ne serait
que quatre personnes il va faire ce s'en
occuper c'est un partenariat qui est
voué à perdurer n'aurait pas fait ces
dons non négligeable deux éditions les
ja d'audition c'est prévu encore pour
deux ans et deux années de suite
donc on n'ira pas jusqu'au jeux de 2024
pour l'instant mais et c'est bien parti
pour 2020 c'est sûr pour terminer ce que
vous avez un pronostic cette rencontre
je vais un peu chauvin 1 puisque
l'équipe d'issy paris 2eme actuellement
donc elles ont raté de façon très bête
le match d'hier soir pour faire un match
nul alors qu'elle menait à dix secondes
de la fin quoi donc il va falloir gagner
ce match et donc elles sont tout à fait
capables de le faire donc un score
éventuellement à ben même un petit but
de plus ça va bien est ce que les lignes
noires
voilà une victoire est ce que les
lionnes vont croquer les vipères de
kristiansand on verra merci à vous
dépasser sur ce bateau est d'avoir
répondu à nos questions bon courage pour
l'organisation de cet événement patrie
merci à vous en football le fc et long
cours fait désormais partie d'un cercle
très fermé de 13 club yvelinois qui ont
ici obtenir le label jeune fff espoir
une récompense délivrée par les
instances du football français qui sera
effectif jusqu'en 2020 pour les
catégories de jeunes 8,5 à u19 a remise
de ce label s'est déroulée ce samedi à
midi au stade guy-boniface les réactions
micro de nicolas nourrit une grande
fierté
la récompense du travail accompli par
par tous que ce soit le bureau les
dirigeants les joueurs on espère qu'il
ya des joueurs que des joueurs qui sont
déjà chez nous reste ce fût soit
fidéliser par par ce label que ça amène
aussi d'autres joueurs des clubs à
l'endos qu'ils y va choisir entre
un club ou un autre à prendre plutôt
celui qui est labellisé le club créé en
1991 compte près de 600 joueurs de la
catégorie u15 à u19 ils sont encadrés
par près de 80 dirigeants et 18
éducateurs du football on passe au
badminton dernière journée du
championnat régional ce dimanche 28
janvier et l'encours a réussi à
accrocher les barrages pour éviter la
descente au niveau inférieur
un nul face à fontenay le fleury une
victoire face à l'équipe de rueil
malmaison ont suffi aux badistes élan
courtois récit de cette dernière
rencontre par nicolas landry
elles ont apporté le match de la
victoire les élans courtoise mélanie
guen et anaïs pointillart ont remporté
leur double le score de 7 0 ce succès
permet au volant d'elancourt d'accéder
aux barrages de maintien en division
honneur
[Musique]
sur les huit rencontres face à l'équipe
2 de rueil malmaison et l'encours a
remporté six matchs les élans courtoise
honte oeuvré pour cette victoire seul
bémol les deux simple masculin
axel tadié nicolas mon plots ont causé
des chacun une défaite
le point fort c'est les filles et dans
quasiment tous les clubs de des yvelines
notre gros point fort c'est les filles
on a des filles très performante et
c'est grâce à elle faudra pas leur dire
mais c'est grâce à elle qu'on gagne sur
les doubles hommes et les simples hommes
on pèche un peu nous manque un peu
ce petit quelque chose pour aller
chercher le money-time souvent dans le
troisième set qui est par notre faveur
sur cette saison des difficultés sur
cette saison due aussi à des blessures
prochain rendez vous pour les volants
d'elancourt le week end du 17 et 18 mars
pour les matches de barrage et peut-être
à la clé le maintien c'est une première
dans les yvelines camy baradji
originaire de voisins-le-bretonneux a
été élue miss fitness france 2018 cette
grande sportive de 29 ans pratique la
musculation deux à trois fois par
semaine et enseignes des cours de zumba
entre montigny le bretonneux et voisins
le bretonneux pour remporter ce concours
la vie sinoise a été évalué sur ses
capacités ont développé couché en
pompant squat et l'endurance les images
de à mélanie poké une vraie force de la
nature à 29 ans caddie baradji réalise
en moyenne de 25 heures de sport par
semaine et peut soulever jusqu'à 80 kg
des performances qui lui ont permis de
devenir miss fitness france à créteil en
novembre dernier
j'avais vraiment envie de me dépasser 2
d'arriver au bout et d'indiens j'ai fait
tout ce que je pouvais que je gagne ou
pas en fait de d'être allé au bout de
moi même dans une compétition où c'était
pas mon domaine en fait pour réaliser
cet exploit cet ancien athlète et
tenniswoman d'un mètre soixante huit
pour 60 kg a dû remporter plusieurs
épreuves sur une journée un concours
loin d'être une promenade de santé
il y avait des séances de force un peu
qu'avec squat développé couché
il y avait des pompes à des tractions
des abdos des lombaires et un gros
circuit un peu cheap comme ce que je
viens de faire là et c'était vraiment
complet pour remporter ces épreuves
spartiates kddi a travaillé pendant un
mois de façon intense avec son
entraîneur dans cette salle de maurepas
je savais qu'elle allait gagner sans
aucun doute
c'est fou tout le temps sourit tout le
temps zumba la danse tennis crossfit
vitesse tout ce qu'ils roulaient en
permanence musculation le jour et encore
du sport le soir en parallèle de ces
grosses séances de fitness caddie donne
des cours de pilates de renforcement
musculaire et surtout de zumba cinq fois
par semaine entre voisins le bretonneux
et montigny le bretonneux
allez les filles on y va du parti pour
moi personnellement je préfère faire les
pompes et les fractions met à enseigner
à la zumba c'est vraiment très sympa ça
allie la dépense physique et le plaisir
en fait c'est à dire que c'est vraiment
fun on se rend pas compte qu'on est dans
l'effort
[Musique]
chaque soir une vingtaine d'élèves
viennent participer à ces sessions ce
sont eux qui l'ont poussé à s'inscrire
au concours miss fitness france victoire
de la professeur a donc été accueillie
avec de grands sourires à bord
non
l'histoire de caddie avec le monde du
sport n'est pas prêt de se terminer la
sportive envisage de défendre son titre
de miss fitness france l'année prochaine
et de participer à d'autres concours de
kickboxing comme vous pouvez le voir sur
cette image de champion du monde de la
discipline ciré la bnsa camp était au
gymnase de toussus le noble
le sportif de 28 ans participer à un
stage organisé par l'académie skd box
nouvelle antenne de ce club déjà présent
à montigny le bretonneux champions
délivré pendant plus de 2h30 ses
conseils à une quarantaine de sportifs
la section ouvrira officiellement ses
portes au mois de septembre
on passe maintenant à l'agenda du
week-end on commence cet agent d'un
parent de la course à pied le 37e cross
de la sablière est organisée ce dimanche
4 février à viroflay entre la forêt de
meudon et versailles près de 1000
coureurs sont attendus pour ce rendez
vous pour nous parler de cet événement
nous recevons sur ce plateau le
président de l'usf viroflay jean pierre
rouyer et deux autres organisateurs
sylvain fresnel et pascal gallois
bonsoir alors le cross de la sablière
c'est ce dimanche est-ce que tout est
prêt présidera je pense que oui on a
fait tout ce qu'il fallait pour qu'on
soit prêt dans les temps donc les
inscriptions monte en pression pour
encore s'inscrire jusqu'à samedi toute
la journée au siège du club et dimanche
matin sur place moyennant un supplément
de tarif alors l'édition 2017 avait été
annulé pour des raisons d'organisation
est ce que c'est un soulagement de
repartir cette année en 2018 oui parce
que je pense qu à viroflay
tout le monde attend cross c'est un
événement au delà du
l'événement sportif ces événements
comment culturel
d'ailleurs le maire de viroflay a parlé
même de monuments sportifs de la ville
de viroflay donc tout le monde attend le
cros à viroflay
et je pense que tous les autres bureaux
plaisir seront présents dimanche matin
se concentrer c'est une page de
l'histoire on peut le dire de viroflay
il existe depuis 1977 il va freiner
oui c'est bel une belle page d'histoire
de la ville et du sport en général
il a marqué plusieurs générations se
croisent c'est un événement familial je
l' ai couru déjà très très petit pense
qu'on va retrouver encore plusieurs
générations sans doute les grands
parents les parents et beaucoup
d'enfants on espère ce dimanche alors le
parcours est un donc un cross-country de
6 à 11 kilomètres
quelle est la différence entre les deux
à part la distance bien sûr alors il ya
une deuxième boucle
du coup bon un petit peu plus de
dénivelé pour le format long du coup
difficulté intéressante un très très
beau terrain de jeu non dans cette forêt
des parties plates des descentes des
relances des virages de quoi vraiment
s'amuser avec parcours sans doute très
boueux dimanche prochain le parcours a
été modifié depuis 1977
oui on a revu notamment la zone de
départ et d'arrivée pour le l'imaginé
plus plus convivial plus facile d'accès
mettre de nouvelles installations
du coup on a revu un petit peu le
parcours sur le début à la fin le
parcours est il compliqué parce qu'il
faut avoir de bonnes jambes
silva frais des deux bonnes jambes oui
des bonnes chaussures serait que la
avoir besoin des semelles qui avec pas
mal d'un croche comme j'ai dit le
parcours s'annonce forcément bout et on
espère quand même ne pas avoir depuis
dimanche prochain pascal vous êtes
d'accord c'est un parcours compliqué oui
parcours compliqué que nous avons
reconnu sylvain champiré mois vallonné
très très beau parcours dans la forêt du
ruf les il ya des codes des dessins des
beaux virages des singles
tout le monde y trouvera son bonheur
c'est magnifique et tout le monde peut
participer à cette compétition
tout le monde peut participer
donc les bagages de 1000 adultes les
enfants sont aussi conviés puisqu'il ya
des courses pour enfants très jeunes
enfants
et puis voilà tout le monde peut
participer y compris les personnes
handicapées que nous en demandons
il ya également oui justement on va en
parler juste après il ya également aussi
un challenge maman enfant
oui ces nouveautés cette année c'est
cette année effectivement pour lancer de
ce côté familial pour lancer aussi le
sport féminin donc une maman qui
s'inscrit avec son enfant il y aura un
tirage au sort à l'arrivée forcément
puisque les mamans ont pas forcément le
même âge et les enfants non plus
d'ailleurs et puis aussi des filles et
des garçons mais je pense que jusqu'à
maintenant il y aura un très beau
challenge nouveauté avec un bijou qui
est offert par un bijoutier de viroflay
bijoux de création et donc je pense que
cette nouveauté va attirer beaucoup de
monde et vous disais juste avant il ya
des sportifs du coup handicapés qui vont
participer à la compétition il y aura
des jeux est oui nous aurons deux
joëlettes des dunes d'espoir avec deux
jeunes enfants anthony ego qui grâce à
quelques coureurs qui seront là pour
tous et les tirs et les geôles est donc
je passion dans les geôles est là qui
est gras salés un ensemble de coureurs
qui sont là pour pousser tirer les
chouettes ces jeunes enfants anthony &
go pourront aussi profiter du bonheur de
participer à cette course il y aura
également une opération caritative avec
les bouchons l'espoir oui oui notre
associé notre associant l'ensemble des
bénéfices est reversée à la chaîne
d'espoir donc là sociaux dans ce parti
et les bouchons de l'espoir sont
présents sur le cross mais cette année
tout au moins il n'y a pas de
reversement de bénéfices peut-être une
autre fois mais déjà nous sommes
présents c'est déjà très beau les
enfants sont très heureux de participer
à cette course sont des moments défense
solidaire émouvant et joyeux
c'est très très sympathique et merci à
jean pierre d'accueillir les les
joëlettes dernière question président
est ce qu il reste encore des places
bien sûr
son acquéreur du monde jusqu'à dimanche
matin on a tout mis en
en place pour que personne ne soit
refusé dimanche matin mais bien sûr
l'intérêt c'est comme de ses de
s'inscrire le plus tôt possible et au
plus tard cinq préférence pour des
questions d'organisation également merci
à tous les trois avaient passé sur ce
plateau je rappelle le départ du 11 km
du cross de la sablière est programmée
ce dimanche à 10h40 c'est la fin de 7,8
sport merci d'avoir suivi on se retrouve
lundi prochain pour un nouveau magazine
d'ici là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]